let's talk about the only carbohydrate that will
not influence insulin now as you may know insulin
is the hormone that makes you fat it's the hormone
that prevents you from burning fat and it's a fat
storing hormone so in the presence of
even a little bit of insulin it's going
to be very difficult to lose weight and get into
ketosis so the only carb that has absolutely no
influence over insulin is fiber okay now the
problem with fiber is it normally comes with
other carbs that do influence insulin as in the
bread pasta cereal crackers biscuits waffles
things like that and so many times people
are recommending those foods because
it has fiber but what about the other carbs that
are not fiber we want to stay away from them
now just as a side note pure fat will also not
increase insulin but what does increase insulin
is the sugar the starches and excessive amounts
of protein so is it just a matter of getting some
fiber maybe some metamucil on a spoon and then
pour some pure fat on it right no the type of
fiber that you need is in the non-starchy leafy
greens it's in the vegetables and this is why you
don't have to count non-starchy vegetables when
you're doing the ketogenic diet as a part of your
grams of carbohydrate normally you want to keep
your carbs below 30 maybe 40 grams maybe even
20 grams but i don't recommend even counting the
non-starchy vegetables like the salads and things
in fact unless you have some intestinal damage or
inflammatory condition that causes bloating when
you eat a lot of vegetables i recommend you do add
a good amount of vegetables as part of a healthy
keto plan and i'm talking at least seven cups it's
not that much it's like a nice sized salad but
what do these vegetables give you besides fiber
well it gives you minerals potassium magnesium
to prevent cramps when you start the ketogenic
diet to prevent keto fatigue when you start the
ketogenic plant also these vegetables have trace
minerals they're loaded with vitamins like vitamin
c folate other b vitamins they have a tremendous
amount of phytonutrients which go beyond just the
regular vitamins and minerals phytonutrients are
anti-cancer anti-inflammatory and they will help
prevent a lot of different issues but as far
as the fiber in the vegetable that is the food
for your microbiome for your friendly bacteria
that's what they eat and then they turn that fiber
into a type of fat it's called a small chain
fatty acid as in beta hydroxybutyrate which is a
ketone so butyrate made from your microbes is in
the family of ketones so microbes eat the fiber
and they make compounds that help
lessen insulin resistance which is
directly going to help you lose weight because
they also help lower blood glucose they can
actually increase insulin sensitivity which will
then make it easier to lose weight which means
your body won't have to make as much insulin and
that's going to help your weight loss the fiber
also increases the diversity of microbes which
will have another positive effect on weight loss
all right thanks for watching hey before you
go if you're benefiting from any of my content
i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below